I won't be doing limbo on station but if
you want to challenge me in limbo later
I'm all for it so I'm very excited to be
here I came all the way from Norway for
this conference it's been awesome so far
thanks to all of you the organizers and
the speakers of course so now we're
going to talk a little bit more about
streams and how we've embraced
functional reactive programming to build
a large single page application at our
dock so at our dock we try to help
businesses answer any question about how
their organization is tied together we
do this by modeling them as a graph so
we map out their applications business
capabilities their infrastructure and
then how it all ties together it's a
fairly client-side heavy app with
dynamically generated visualizations
real-time collaboration and also an
interesting mix of technologies that
we're gonna get go a bit into so for
this talk we're first gonna define some
concepts to give you an intro to streams
and functional reactive programming then
we're gonna hopefully give you some
motivation for why you should care and
then we're going to present some
building blocks for building an app with
rxjs and also reflect on some roadblocks
that we've hit along the way so
functional reactive programming how many
of you have used it before please raise
a hand it's a few not that many I think
I can't see because of the lights but
essentially reactive programming is
programming with data streams so streams
that emit data over time and if you look
at the modern JavaScript libraries that
most of us use actually a lot of them
embody some of the principles of
reactive programming so in redux and ng
RX for example you have the store which
emits the application state over time so
that is essentially a stream right what
we do in reactive programming though is
we elevate Street
and we treat them as first class
citizens and the functional part comes
from the fact that we composed them
functionally so we mapped them filter
and reduce there are many libraries in
JavaScript for working with streams and
in this talk we're gonna focus on rxjs
which is probably the most popular one I
think it surpassed a million downloads
this year and it's also the only
dependency of angular so rxjs is a
library for transforming composing and
querying streams of data it implements
the observable type in JavaScript and
the observable is essentially a stream
and many people call it low - for
streams I think it's quite powerful
though so I rather like this definition
and I hope you will see that as well so
the observable was made popular in
reactive extensions rx in.net I think
about 10 15 years ago and what it
allowed us was to work with async code
more more easily and when introducing
the observable I like to compare with
promises as I think most of us have
worked with promises so whereas a
promise emits a single value at a time
observables emit multiple values over a
period of time a promise is not lazy it
begins processing upon creation so if
you create a promise which fetches data
it starts fetching immediately whereas
an observable is lazy so you can declare
an observable that should fetch data
from an API but it won't actually start
fetching until you subscribe to it
till something subscribes to it yeah
whereas a promise can't be canceled
observables can be canceled seamlessly
and this can be quite powerful in some
web applications a lot of the core
contributors of rxjs work at Netflix and
their canonical example is when a user
starts buffering a video and then goes
back you want to cancel the first
operation and with promises this can be
quite complex while with observables
it's seamless and kind of reflecting on
these properties I think the more
complex our single page applications
become the more things kind of emit over
time and the observable pattern fits
much better for dealing with this than
promises
another reason for
why you should care is that the
observable is stage one proposal in
JavaScript so it might actually become a
part of our language and our XG s have
also done a lot of work in trying to
marrying that proposal so how do we come
across rx yes we needed to build a
separate single page application we went
with Redux then we needed a way to
handle async and for simple applications
you might be fine with redux thunk but
if you have more complex data flows then
you probably want to look into Redux
agha or redux observable and we chose
Redux observable and that was kind of
our gateway drug to two streams yeah so
on the left side here you have a typical
redux application or a flux like
architecture where you have views that
trigger actions these actions are
reduced in the store then the views
again subscribe to the store to read the
application state what we Doug's
observable does is it also adds epics
into the mix where we contain our side
effects so epics take in actions and can
also read the store and then they emit
new actions and these the store and
actions are represented at our as our X
es streams so you can apply several
operators to them and write fairly
complex async code seamlessly and for us
streams really made sense so for the
actions in store I mean they emit over
time so representing them as a stream
makes sense but then if you think of
your web applications you also have
click events Dom events user interaction
everything kind of emits over time
you also have WebSocket events and
thinking of these as streams kind of
liber8 cyou as it makes it much easier
to model complex data flow and you might
even think of everything is a stream
eventually at least for us that kind of
became the case and this is our much I
wouldn't building applications and while
we were super Zen like this dog
meditating thinking about streams
suddenly reality kicked in and that's
that we needed to fix our core app so we
had build a small app
vacation on the side with Redux
observable in our yes but then we had
our main application which I show it
earlier and it was in a quite dire state
with vast amounts of technical debt so
as I said our dock is a start-up and for
the first four years we were trying to
find product market fit and what that
meant was that we needed to add a lot of
new features without thinking much about
technical debt or dealing with that and
in kind of the in the JavaScript world
that also meant that we took a lot of
shortcuts introduced a lot of new
libraries and it led to a mix of
paradigm so don't mix well together
we had a new colleague join two years
ago and he said that our app basically
showcased the history of web development
Hey
it had a mix of jQuery backbone
handlebars react Redux like all that all
the good stuff for the bad stuff so it's
really hard to reason about what was
going on there was also very little
separation of concerns so if you kind of
change something over here this other
thing broke and also state was all over
the place and it was really hard to
reason about what's going on and I think
that's kind of what we're Redux for
example to saved us is that it allowed
us to think easier about our state and
we we were not really there so the plans
for the New York texture was first that
we have to read our connector mid-flight
I mean we're still a startup we don't
have a lot of developers so we can't
simply build a new app on the side so we
need to start decoupling our app then we
need to be able to reason about our
state we also need good interrupts with
legacy state and views so new views need
to interrupt with old state and old
views and rxjs and redux was introduced
but then we started thinking do we
really need Redux and it was great for
starting from scratch but it was not
really obvious how we introduced it in a
legacy app especially since we had a lot
of state all over the place simply
adding a Redux tour would mean that we
had another state manager so it became
an even bigger mess and if you read the
Redux documentation they mention our
exists and they say it works well
together with Redux but I'm gonna
highlight this one paragraph and that's
where they asked do you really need
Redux if you already
use our X maybe not it's not hard to
re-implement redux in our ex and that's
essentially what we did so we define
these building blocks which are very
similar to a redux architecture to flux
like architecture we have the action
stream which ties everything together
that is subscribed by the state stream
which calculates the application state
based on actions then we have view
streams which is a layer in between the
state and our views which prepares the
state for the views so that the views
can be as simple as possible essentially
pure functions of view streams
finally we have routines and that's
where we contain our side effects so
similar to epics and redux observable
and they also allow us to kind of D
couple our application so we're going to
jump into each each one of these so the
action stream allows any part of the
application to communicate we define it
as a subject so a subject is a type of
an observable whereas an observable
emits data over time you can also push
data to a subject using the dot next
method so essentially it's a publish and
subscribe mechanism and with these two
lines of code we can dispatch our first
action and launch a rocket into ISKCON
however nothing is handling this action
yet so for that we introduce routines
routines handle actions and produce side
effects so here's an example of a
routine it pipes the action stream and
piping essentially means taking a stream
applying a set of operators and creating
a new stream and what routine should do
is it should eventually emit side
effects right so what we do here is we
filter on the launch rocket action then
we map that to fetching of coordinates
which could be an API call to get the
coordinates and finally if that fetches
successfully we dispatch an action to
proceed and these are three different
rxjs operators of type is custom and in
the middle we have switch map and I
purposefully chose switch map instead of
flat
map to show cancellation essentially
what switch map does is if it starts
fetching coordinates and that takes a
long time and then another action is
dispatched to launch another rocket the
first one would be canceled so that's
how cancellation can easily be built
into streams so routines allow us to
decouple our application because modules
can simply define what they should react
to and our views and other modules can
dispatch actions so there it allows us
to to decouple them first that helped a
lot because we had basically a spaghetti
monster
if one service needed to use another it
basically imported it and then you have
if that needs to use the other one then
you have circular dependencies and once
everything goes over the action stream
it's much easier to build a modular
application and then we hit our first
roadblock and that was dead streams so
what a stream may die essentially you
need to catch your heirs with RCS so in
this example if we fetch coordinates and
that API call fails then it wouldn't
proceed and that makes sense as you
would expect however if you then try to
launch a new rocket it will not fetch
coordinates because the stream is dead
and how you circumvent that is by
catching errors so with ours yes you
need to catch errors in in order to keep
your streams alive and that is actually
a pretty good feature I think because it
makes it forces you to catch errors and
define how your application should
handle them of course for
production-ready code you might want to
make it more robust by centralizing
stream creation so that you have some
global error handlers as well next we
have state streams so so far we have
actions and routines but we haven't
really done anything to replace Redux
state streams emit the state of our
application and here is an example of a
state stream so the rocket stream pipes
the action stream and accumulate state
over time so if you dispatch action to
launch a rocket it will D
ferment the fuel of the rocket and I
think for many of you this probably
looks familiar it's basically a reducer
except it's now modeled as a stream and
now that it's modeled as a stream we can
also do a lot of different things with
them there we're gonna go into so one
thing is that we can have derived state
so oftentimes in your applications you
have state which depends on base state
for example we could have refuelling
cost which should be calculated using
the fuel price for example so here we
pluck the fuel then from the rocket
stream then we apply distinct until
changed with that it does is it adds
memoization so essentially it won't emit
until the fuel changes then we combine
it with a fuel price stream and fuel
price could be defined as an API call so
then when something subscribes to this
it would also do an API call to get the
latest fuel price and finally we map
that to to the refueling cost and
normally if you would have memorization
in a Narita except you would have to add
reselect while with Arceus you have
operators that that can support that
next we have proxy state so going back
to our requirements we have a lot of
legacy states and we need could
interrupt with that what we can do with
our XE acids we can create our own
stream creators and essentially stream
our legacy state so what we do here is
we create an observable from a backbone
model we define so that whenever a
backbone model syncs with the server it
also pushes that to an observable so
then in our new application code we can
simply subscribe to these streams and
they won't really know about backbone
being under the hood so that we can then
later swap out backbone easily so the
benefits of state streams is that
they're quite expressive and powerful
yet easy to reason about so going back
to this slide we have memoization built
in we combine it with another API as
well and it's just a few lines of code
and once you get used to
paradigm it's also quite easy to read
then it has good interrupts with legacy
state using proxy state and then you
also once you have your state as streams
you unlock the power of rx GS operators
you could add debouncing you have
memorization with distinct and they'll
change you could add a buffer and there
are many other options as well then we
hit our our next row block and that's
cold versus hot so I think anyone who
starts using rxjs hits this row block
eventually for those of you are not
familiar with cold versus hot it might
also be a bit like ambiguous terms they
didn't make a lot of sense to me the
first time I heard them essentially what
they mean though is that observables are
cold by default and and they can be made
hot so cold observables is they work in
the in the way that every new subscriber
gets its own producer so imagine there's
a observable which models the Fibonacci
sequence the first subscriber will get
the whole sequence and then the second
subscriber would also get the whole
sequence and that that makes sense for
some cases for example with API calls as
well if observable is defined to be an
API call you would expect that every new
subscriber would do a new API call
however for for some cases such as state
streams that's not really efficient
because every new subscriber to the
state stream would create a new producer
so if we have five subscribers to a
state stream it would recalculate the
state every time so what we can do for
state changes we have hot observables
so essentially what that does is that it
shares the producer among all
subscribers so basically cold vs. hot is
a very important property of streams
that has big implications and you need
to kind of think about this when you
when you define your streams and for
state streams it's it's easy we just
make them high
so next we have views and views as
functions of streams so I think and I
hope most of you agree that the view
should be dead simple pure functional
components it makes them decoupled from
our business logic and an easier to
change them later so what we do in our
architecture is that we have view
streams the pipe state streams and then
prepare them for the view so the views
can be as simple as possible and we've
created a connect utility function which
works very similar to connect and react
Redux essentially what it does is it
subscribes to a stream when the view is
mounted and then unsubscribes when it's
unmounted so that the view would update
whenever the the view stream updates
next we can also have view streams that
fetch data so you could define a view
stream as an ajax call so you could
essentially fetch data from the API when
the view mounts and map that to props
for the view using another operator we
could also add initial loading props so
that the view could render something
before the API call results and we could
also catch errors so we're just five H
lines of code and maybe a couple of
utility functions we have a view that is
coupled to an API call without having
that API logic in our view so that is
essentially our our building blocks for
for building an application with our X
yes and now I want to reflect a little
bit on the higher level pitfalls and
benefits of that so one thing is that
our X yes is extremely flexible and you
need to invest some time and kind of
dealing dealing with this flexibility
because you can really shoot yourself in
the foot when they are dealing with it
another thing is that you might end up
with with streams all over the place I
heard a podcast with with Ben Lesh the
creator or the core maintainer of rxjs
and he warns about basically creating
streams all over the place and that's
that's what many people do and I'm like
damn that's
title of my talk and however I think you
can circumvent that problem by being
explicit about your streams and
essentially defining your own building
blocks so kind of the building blocks I
presented it's it's not meant to be a
framework or a silver bullet for
everyone it's rather an architecture
that you can kind of build to suit your
fit your needs and I think our xes is a
great tool for that
next is the debugging can be a bit
challenging in rxjs call stacks are a
little bit yeah hug and hide some
important details however we have tools
also deal with that so you can use rxjs
spy to tag your streams and essentially
then you can also replay your streams
you can stop them similar to how you
would do with Redux dev tools and the
Creator is also working on a Chrome
extension so then we'll have a similar
experience and then the benefits of rxjs
and streams are also that it is
extremely flexible so you can do a lot
of things with the operators that rxjs
provides and I think also one thing is
the kind of the expressiveness of
reactive programming you can write ten
lines of code which with a few operators
and that defines a fairly complicated
async logic and then it's it's still
very easy to reason about and perhaps
the most important point is the with
streams there is very little overhead to
dealing with asynchronous code because
once you kind of embrace streams then
everything can react to anything at any
point in time so you don't really care
about whether it's a sink or a
synchronous so I think in JavaScript at
least I've heard often that we we treat
async sort of as a problem when we want
to contain it but with reactive
programming you just become seamless to
deal with it so then the question is
should you embrace streams and I think
you should if you find that async code
makes things complex in your application
or perhaps if you're working on a large
single page application and it's
difficult to reason about what's going
on that was the case for us at least
obviously adding reactive programming to
makes one solve your problems but I
really think that it can help you reason
about about the data that flows for your
application and next is if you're using
angular or redux observable I think so
and our angler has a single dependency
and that is rx yes but I think many who
use it
haven't really embraced it that much so
it might be worth reading reading more
into it and perhaps also if you use
Redux you should you should really check
out redux observable so I hope this talk
was interesting and that you also might
start thinking about everything as a
stream
[Applause]
[Music]